new in theaters this weekend Jumanji the
next-level bombshell and Richard Jewell
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since never you look like this
never I think my eyes are a different
color all of you is it different color
in the sequel to the successful Jumanji
welcome to the jungle
Jumanji the next level sees the return
of the old gang as well as new players
as a couple of old men gets sucked into
Jumanji with the kids things get mixed
up as everyone gets different avatar
bodies this time and they face new
challenges as they try to save their
friend this movies for you if you love
the first 2 Jumanji movies you're
looking for an action-adventure comedy
this weekend or you're hoping to get
stuck between a rock and a hard place
ask yourself what would scare my
grandmother or piss off my grandfather
and that's a [ __ ] story ma smooch thanks
bombshell revisits the rise of a handful
of female reporters at Fox News as they
combat the stifling masculine controlled
media and we see Charlize Theron star as
megyn kelly a role that's already
getting her Oscar buzz this movies for
you if you're looking for an empowering
movie this weekend you're interested in
this star-studded cast or if you think
I'd look good with blonde hair let me
know in the comments you've always look
at the guy who found the bomb just like
he was with a guy found the body
jewel fits the profile of the lone
bomber based on a true story Richard
Jewell tells the story of a security
guard who finds a bomb at the 1996
Olympics and successfully evacuated the
area but his life changes as well he's
deemed a hero he is also accused of
being a suspect by both the police and
the media
tamson this movies for you if you're
looking for a based on a true story
movie this weekend you're down for a
little suspense or if you're looking for
a little Christmas ham
I know I am that is your weekend ticket
WC and check back next week for one of
the hardest decision between two movies
you'll ever have to make